hi there today we're going to continue
with on the measure of intelligence by
Francois Shirley now if you remember
last time if you haven't seen last time
go watch part 1 if you're interested
this is a multi-part series on this
paper why because the paper itself is
very long it's 40 pages the main part
and it's it's a big wall of text so I've
opted to basically pull out notes and
show you the notes that I have pulled
out and to divide this into multiple
parts so last time we went over sort of
the history of assessing intelligence
and the basics and I know I said this
time I'm going to get into the math but
I lied so I realized that there's still
a lot that comes up in part 2 of the
paper before we get into the actual math
so this part is going to be about the
prerequisites to that and then next time
math I'm sorry to disappoint anyone yeah
you might just skip this one if you want
I do have to shout out Tim scarf who of
course runs the machine learning Street
talk channel podcast with me and Connor
shorten together tim has just made an
entire video about this paper about on
the measure of intelligence and his
videos are usually like super high
quality like higher than mine and it's
the entire paper so if you want to you
know know the end of the story or you
know have a different take on the paper
definitely can recommend his video I do
make a guest appearance there so yeah
that's that's a given and I will still
finish the paper on this channel just in
my regular in this style right here so
all the options are available to you
let's dive into part two so if you
remember part one we sort of went over
what it means to be intelligent and we
differentiated basically two things
which are skills and abilities so a
skill is how well you achieve a given
task or how well you can do in a given
task so this could be chess
or you know go or I'd like something
very very measurable an IQ test is a
specific task so these things right here
are all tasks but these tasks aren't the
thing we're interested in just because
the machine is good at chess doesn't
mean it's intelligent and what we want
is sort of a generalizable skill so we
want to assess how generalizable is an
ability so can I throw a computer at a
new problem that it has never seen
before and it can solve that and that's
going to be this generalizability this
notion of can you solve things that you
have never encountered before and
weren't prepared for that is going to be
the basis for us to measure intelligence
so Shola says you have to optimize
directly for generality and flexibility
rather than task performance if you want
to build a an intelligent agent you have
to sort of build something that is not
just good at a thing it is good at
getting good at things that's that's
almost a quote quote worthy thing so if
you just give it a single task it says
that the learner will will just take any
available shortcuts so if you just say
you have to be good at chess you can the
developer of a system can exploit all
the tricks that make you good at chess
and you don't have to be smart you just
know basically if you had enough memory
you could just memorize all the moves of
all chess games ever okay that's why we
say hard-coded chatbots are not
intelligent so hard code chatbots that
they simply match your input to a
database of reg X's and then they answer
and we're not very impressed because as
soon as I give them something that is
not covered by their reg X's
they they they fail they just say I
don't know or something like this in
fact what is intelligent is the engineer
in that case so the engineer that makes
the program is intelligent so the e yes
this this drawing I think I've shown it
last time where you have
of the environment and there is there is
this this agent and if the agent is
really good with the environment you
might consider that intelligent but
surely in chalets mind you have to also
consider here at the developer of the
agent it could be that the developer is
very intelligent and just builds the
agent to interact with the environment
in a manner that it gets a lot of reward
is very good at a skill but the agent
itself might not be intelligent
so it says intelligence the intelligence
of a process is not encoded by the
performance of a system but by the fact
that the same process can be applied to
different tasks so in this case if I
have a new task a new environment so e -
right here the question is could I throw
the same agent at that even if it hasn't
seen it before or would I be able to
take the same developer that develops me
a new agent agent - that then can solve
the task in in the in the case where I
can throw over the agent that would make
an argument that the agent is
intelligent but if I can't you'd have to
make the argument that the developer is
the intelligent part here which of
course this is the point that what he's
saying right here so hard-coded programs
themselves are not intelligent but and
this is the case the same counts for
adding more training data so not only is
the hard-coding not intelligent it's
also Sholay says not intelligence if you
simply add more training data so a
machine learning system that sort of
learns - how how to interact with these
environments if you can you can imagine
that you have lots of environments
environment environment environment
environment and so on that give you a
dense sampling of the environment space
right so you have all of these
environments you build all of them and
you train this agent to interact well
with all of them so you give it lots of
compute lots of data and the the
environments are really a dense sampling
of the environment space
we'll be able even though it has never
seen environment to write this
environment right here it might be just
able to generalize to this environment
given that it has been trained on all
the environments here like it has been
trained on every possible environment
around this environment that is similar
to this environment it could generally
generalized to environment too
but also we wouldn't view that as
intelligent because it in a sense this
skill has been bought with data and this
notion of buying skill is comes up a lot
in this paper socially says there are
two ways to buy a skill and by buying he
basically means you don't buying as
opposed to intelligently solving the
skill so whenever you buy a skill that's
not intelligence for this and you can
buy a skill by either hard-coding the
solution or giving lots of data and
there is like this spectrum where you
hard-code completely hard-coded solution
and here is where you completely only
feed data so here would be something
like GPT three right there are almost no
priors there it's just a transformer big
transformer and wood and you just throw
in data lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots of data so in this measure I've
last time I've had lots of people when
GPT three came out I've had people
commenting on the part one of this paper
saying isn't GPT three intelligent
because you know it can sort of
generalize to these tasks that it hasn't
been trained on by the way if you
haven't seen the GPT three video you
should go watch it some something tells
me this video is popular it might be
that five times as many views as any
other video so at least it's not a
terrible video but in essence GPT three
can solve these tasks that it wasn't
trained for right and therefore you
might argue in this definition right
here it could be intelligent because it
can generalize but there is this counter
action where Shirley says maybe you have
just bought that skill
with lots and lots of data now I
actually don't know what to say to this
because I mean it really seems like GPT
three generalizes to tasks it has never
seen before but also it has had a lot of
data and so as of right now it is not
really clear where the the line is here
like when when are we gonna argue that
GPT three is actually like it could be
that it has had lots of data but also it
is intelligent how are we going to make
that distinction and I guess we're going
to get into the math part but I can tell
you right now the math part is so
abstract as it is not really practical
it is like a theoretical framework that
you might be able to approximate but you
know there is there is like a
wishy-washy thing going on but he
basically says okay there's this
spectrum of hard coding over here and
then fully learning from data and with
all of these methods and you know in
between methods they like a CNN would be
here because it has like considerable
priors because of its architecture and
so on and over here would be something
like an a-star search with like a
learned heuristic or things like this
you can you can get good with any of
these things but the intelligence is
orthogonal to that so orthogonal to that
is the intelligence axis it has nothing
Shirley says this has nothing to do with
this damage you can buy skill with this
but it's basically like it's like a
triangle almost sort of where you have
hard coding data and then intelligence
and it's like its own axis so the hard
coding refers to the priors of a system
that the developer has basically built
in and the the learning from data refers
to its experience so basically the more
experience it a system has had the more
it can generalize to a new skill that
doesn't mean it's intelligent it just
means add more experience or
respectively more priors
so he example it gives a
locality-sensitive hashing which is
basically like a nearest neighbor method
with enough data can solve any task
right like nearest neighbor enough data
can solve any task that's I think it's
more a famous theorem that that
establishes that so keep keep that in
mind that is why we basically need to
pay it pay attention to how much data
went into this algorithm and sort of
subtract that from our notion of how
good how intelligent it is yeah that's
what he says when we measure
intelligence via skill and this is
really the only thing we can measure we
can only measure how good an agent is at
a given skill anything higher than that
we can't measure so we must measure a
skill but we should factor out priors
and experience and that's going to come
up later we should also pay attention to
generalization difficulty so generally
how difficult is the task to solve given
the experience we had because if the
task is more difficult in a
generalization sense so if it's harder
to from what we know get to the point
where we can solve the task then that
would display higher intelligence yeah
he says solving tasks via experience in
priors has nothing to do with
intelligence it's just more experience
more priors so goes back to human
intelligence he says how Universal is
actually human intelligence and it gets
to the to the point where he says it's
not very universal because first of all
there's no free lunch theorem where it
it says any to optimization algorithms
will perform the same if you integrate
across all possible problems so it's
even questionable whether something like
general intelligence
khadeem like universal intelligence
could even exist but if we look at the
DG factor which is used sometimes to
assess human intelligence
Norris is the measure for human
intelligence that is established right
now then they only encompass tasks that
humans can
form and understand of course and I
would say they only encompass tasks
where human actually differ with respect
to each other because if you're making
these tests and you have a human for 40
minutes or so you're not gonna give the
humans tasks where they don't
differentiate from one another so it's
going to be arranged like a a very very
small subset of tasks that are exactly
hard enough such that a couple of humans
can solve them a couple of humans can't
solve them they're going to be you know
understandable by humans so and
understandable ideally by any human you
know you don't have to have special pre
knowledge not have studied biology in
order to answer the questions or not you
know have a higher degree in math or
something so I'm the reference for the G
factor is very much a reference frame of
human values and he compares this to
physical fitness so if we call someone
physically fit what what do we mean we
mean this general abstract concept right
of physical fitness where we it's not
really one skill so you can measure
humans in how fast they run how high
they jump you know how fast they swim
and so on and how how much they can lift
and across that you'll find generally
that all of these things correlate and
the result we call physical fitness but
it's not like physical fitness is a
universal measure so it's we only
measure humans at tasks that humans can
solve and are different at so the he
physical fitness is very human centric
and so is intelligence so that's the
analogy is I think it's a very good one
he says he gives this example where
humans are for example very very good at
shortest path traveling salesman
problems give up to a certain number of
nodes in the graph humans can solve them
extremely well to like very good degree
but as soon as you go to longest path
problem which shouldn't be it that much
harder if you just look
get it from it from an algorithmic
perspective but humans are terrible at
it absolutely terrible and that probably
has to do with the fact that we have a
prior and the prior is much much more
adapt to shortest path problems than
longest path problems because in our
history in our evolutionary history it
made a lot of sense to build in the
navigational unit in the brain that
calculates shortest routings but it's
it's probably like the the your Fitness
is not very much affected by you being
able to calculate the longest path
unless you wanna you know really avoid
some something and just yeah I don't I
don't know you don't really want to walk
in these shoes so that should be taken
into effect and it shows that
intelligence is a very human centric
concept so this when we talk about
general artificial intelligence we what
we mean is it's tied to to a scope of
problems and that's going to be
important that we can only measure
intelligence in this framework with
respect to a scope of problems and the
scope that we consider is the human
scope yeah so why human centric because
we must have a scope and the human scope
is the only meaningful scope it's the
only one we know that you know there is
one thing in the universe that we think
is intelligent that we know of and
that's humans and or to a degree like
what can make the argument it's a
general biological life on earth but we
measure intelligence with a human scope
intelligence test and that's the thing
we have we don't have anything else so
yeah so we ask ourselves what are priors
of humans
what has evolution built into humans and
surely decides on three levels of priors
the low level priors which are like
reflexes so if if I if I pinch you you
you flip you flick
if I flick you you you move back and if
I shine a bright light at your eyes you
close them and so on
so this surely says it's not very
interesting because as I say nothing to
do like we feel that it has nothing to
do with intelligence okay
and then there are skip this one say
there are knowledge priors so the
knowledge priors are you know things
like the fact that there are objects in
this world that's a knowledge prior that
the human have that's built into you the
the notion that the world consists of
objects and you can inter interact with
this with these objects right the
navigation capability we we say okay
navigate there humans can do it very
very well as I already said they're very
good at shortest path problems and so on
intuitive navigation that's built into
you by evolution that's a prior goal
directed nests humans generally view the
world in terms of agents and in terms of
agents having a goal like chasing after
something he makes this example and if
we observe something we often want to
frame it in terms of agents that pursue
goals and as soon as we can do that that
allows us to some degree to predict the
world and that's probably why this
evolved so very valuable skill social
intuition and things like counting like
basic arithmetic are built into humans
and shalay says if we measure
intelligence this is what we must
account for okay so these these things
should not count towards intelligence
because they're already built into
humans if we measure human intelligence
so you wouldn't give you and test human
intelligence by making them count
because that's built into the humans now
the third kind of priors that human have
are meta-learning priors and the
meta-learning priors is basically your
ability to learn something okay this is
your meta learning
just your ability to learn something
that is not learned no one has to teach
you how to learn something I guess
they're like learning strategies and so
on but you as a human are incredibly
good at picking up new skills and the
skill of picking up new skills that's
your that's built into you
among these are assumptions that the
world is a hierarchical and causal place
that's how you see the world and because
you see the world like this you can pick
up these new skills very very quickly
can explain through explaining the world
you can pick up new skills and that is
usually what we mean by intelligence if
someone sees a new unencumbered the
world in the hierarchical and causa way
and then is able to come up with a skill
that solves the problem and we generally
view that as intelligence so if we want
to measure intelligence we should
measure this basically how good you are
picking up new skills while accounting
for these things
okay when we compare to humans so Shola
says tests of intelligence should be
founded on human-like knowledge priors
and basically makes the case that these
should if we build machines and compare
them to humans in let's say in terms of
intelligence we should build into the
machines these things right here these
we should give them like we should give
them a counting module that they can use
like a calculator app we should just
build that in and make that available
for the agent to use like basic
arithmetic shouldn't have to learn this
we should build in the notion that there
are objects we should build in the basic
navigation module and so on that the the
agent can use you can almost think of it
like you know there is whatever your
your reinforcement learning agent a it
consists of like this maybe this big
neural network with lots of layers but
then each layer maybe has access to you
know the calculator app right here
and each layer has access to maybe also
memory I would I would guess memory as
one of those priors as well or you know
it has access to a navigation prior
let's draw a little world map right here
this is Google Maps it can do that it
can query that sort of and we shouldn't
if we want to build something that's
intelligent and compared to humans we
shouldn't we should build in the
navigation we shouldn't at least as much
as human can do it I mean it's cool to
have a machine learning system learn
navigation but that makes it less
comparable so it says either we should
match the humans or we should account
for the difference so we should kind of
let the difference be in that the
difference between the humans and the
machines into the measure of our
intelligent of the intelligence further
if you test intelligence all of these
priors should be explicitly described
and not rely on additional priors so
that's often the case in IQ tests there
are so many priors that are not
explicitly described because we just you
know we just think yeah every human can
count we don't need to to write down
that our prior assumptions are the
humans can count or understand language
and that's I hear sometimes a problem in
IQ tests that basically the better you
understand language the better you score
at these tests and therefore the the
tests are more like a measure of
language ability than intelligence so
there this is a lot much informed by so
I think the Adi psychometrics community
is on the same path right here yeah he
goes into this theory of human core
knowledge where he basically expands on
what the human priors are so the this
core knowledge theory takes four takes
on four different categories so the
first one is object nestled elementary
physics which means you as a human have
an inherent knowledge that there are
objects as I said but also of elementary
physics that stuff sticks to
gather persistence of objects and some
people say you know this is learned so
children young children they do they do
not know object persistence and that's
why peekaboo is so interesting but
because they think you've gone right
they think you know if parent goes to
the to the toilet they really think the
parent doesn't exist anymore and only
later they learn object persistence but
I would question whether or not that's
actually a learn thing or simply a
built-in module that gets switched on at
that particular point because probably
evolution deems it not necessary to to
waste resources on that module before
that so I would you know I would I would
be cautionary saying that object
persistence and all of these things in
fact are learned
I I would argue more that they are
built-in and are simply switched on at a
given time during development because we
also know these things like if like
object persistence I think that's you
can almost pinpoint the month of a
human's life when that switched on that
will be so accurate and if this is
really learned then you know you'd have
to assume like a very regular structure
of the training data distribution that a
baby gets to experience so I'm not sure
here but you know it's not my opinion
it's a shoelace yeah contact interaction
the fact that you can interact with
objects by contacting them they or that
objects can interact with each other by
being next to each other that's built
into you as well you don't have to learn
that if you compare this to like an RL
agent that has to learn all of this from
pixels basically you can see why chalet
has a problem with the current direction
of deep learning and claiming that
things are intelligent there because the
comparison is just very invalid so the
second core knowledge you have is agent
nests and goal-directed nests and we
have already discussed that then natural
number
an elementary arithmetic in you know you
can small numbers you can add subtract
compare sort that sort of thing and
elementary geometry and topology where
in there would be no orientation and
navigation and then distance orientation
if it's something is inside or outside
of in a room and so on now I have heard
and this might be a myth that there are
languages where left and right like
relative directions have no meaning like
doesn't exist in the language but they
always use absolute directions and then
these people automatically like have a
much much better orientation at all time
like if they get into a building they
can always tell you where North is I
don't that's maybe that's a myth but I
would guess that's pretty cool and just
shows you the flexibility of something
like orientation sure we can all orient
but it seems like by simply learning a
different language you can sort of
supercharge that that drive for
orientation so again this it sort of
feels like there is a lot of nature
versus nurture going on in here and that
all of these things yes you probably
have a tendency built in to learn object
nests and physics and so on but then
also probably a lot of it might be
learned in addition or you might just be
able to you know supercharge one of
these modules that's inside of you yeah
I think there's there's lots of lots of
room for discussion here
so he says tests for intelligence should
only involve core knowledge and the AI
systems taking these tests should hard
code that core knowledge so basically
what he said before we should build in
these things right here these core
knowledge things we should build these
into the AI systems if we want to
compare them to humans because if they
have these things and only these things
built in then they sort of have the same
starting point as a human now in the in
this case this is where I sort of
disagree because like the the notion
that we can
explicitly lists the priors that humans
have to me seems a bit ridiculous so I
guess we can we can sort of approximate
this at first but we will never
exhaustively exactly describe what the
priors are what is learned we you know
I've seen this with the orientation like
how much of that is learned and prior
and then secondly even if we could list
them pretty exactly what says that we
can exactly program them into and like
an agent
such that it can make use of it like
that's an entirely that's an even harder
challenge so I'm not so sure about this
AI systems should hard code core
knowledge he's gonna try that with this
arc challenge that we're going to look
at in like the last part of this series
but and it's a cool test for
intelligence I admit that but I I doubt
that anyone really manages to hard-code
the core knowledge and he says test
should only involve core knowledge and
we're going to see how you know how
valid that that claim is for his own arc
challenge now luckily in the math part
that's gonna come up he he doesn't he
doesn't strictly rely on these things so
he gives us a way how we can compare
even if the priors of two systems are
different we can compare which one's
more intelligent all right so that was
part two of this series you know it's
it's already been a while now and this
is only part two and I do promise next
time we're gonna get into the math and I
hope you like this and go check out Tim
scarves video on the same topic yeah as
I said usually much higher quality
videos than mine and I'll see you next
time bye bye